you want to see what they're doing
in Chattanooga Tennessee
Chattanooga Tennessee is supposed to be
a right-wing place they just held a
youth
gay pride event
these are words that should not go in
the same sentence ever
they hold a youth gay pride event at
which a little girl
was was massaging stroking the the groin
of one of the performers I don't even
know if the performer was a man or a
woman
by way of Robbie Starbuck
we've blurred out the girl's face and
it's really horrifying but you can still
make it out a little bit blurry she's
just stroking this person's pelvis I
don't know if it's a man I don't know if
it's a woman
he's he or she is dressed up in a
mermaid costume then you've got some
other pervert jumps out in drag wearing
a tiny little mini skirt lifts his leg
up for it to a tiny little kid
then you got another one walking around
with this one is clearly a dude dressed
up in Drag
shaking his exposed derriere to what
looks like I don't know an eight or nine
year old boy
that's happening in Chattanooga
Tennessee
so if you vote for the Democrats if you
vote for the labels you're voting for
this stuff and that's a lot different
than well I think we should have
slightly more immigration well I think
we should maybe raise tax rates on
corporations a little bit that is this
is some sick demonic stuff and if you
vote for these people you are supporting
this and I I think
I think you're going to be held morally
accountable for this
okay in in this life in the life of the
world to come more importantly I just
it's not good for your soul it's not
good for the country there's no reason
to support these people I I have to ask
myself why is this happening in the
middle of the country
you actually don't see stuff this crazy
in
San Francisco
or in New York City you see plenty of
crazy stuff out there but you you would
expect to see crazier things in San
Francisco and New York and Chicago and
wherever but you don't it's it's these
weird towns in Iowa or Mississippi or
now Chattanooga where you're seeing the
craziest version of this stuff little
kids actually stroking the genitals of
these drag pervert performers
to a bunch of clapping seals who are who
are their their parents who should have
their kids taken away from them and and
the other adults in the room
why I think that shows you the power
of this kind of cultural imperialism
that you're seeing from the libs
especially in the coastal cities because
the libs in the coastal cities
no matter what they preach
they do tend to want nice things they
tend to be richer they tend to be more
established and they they want to keep
their own kind of
semi-civilized way of life going on but
they preach all this crap to everybody
and then it's it's very often in the
smaller towns that are not as I don't
know immune to the craziest predations
of this radical culture that's where you
see it really explode
where there's there are no guard rails
whatsoever and it goes completely off
the rails but but we would be fooling
ourselves if we say well that's San
Francisco for you that's why okay that's
why I'm I'm in a good old red State like
Tennessee yeah Tennessee is I I'm
breathing much Freer air here in
Tennessee but this crap is coming to
Tennessee and it's coming to Iowa and
it's coming to Mississippi and it's
coming to it's coming to a red State
near you in a red town near you okay
so it's really really a big problem
and we are not going to solve it by
burying our heads in the sand what are
we supposed to do about it well if you
think that that is the end of the line
if you think that that's the bottom of
the slippery slope I got another thing
for you pink news
which is not a satire website it's not a
homophobic website it's an LGBT website
they have a headline why can't gay or
lesbian twins have sex with or marry
each other why is incest wrong between
same-sex siblings and I know the first
reaction to this is going to be one of
absolute revulsion
and then a kind of mockery from from
people on the left the people on the
left who didn't write this and who
aren't running think news
because clearly those leftists are
taking it seriously but some people the
kind of moderate lives you're gonna say
oh come on come on that's a slippery
slope argument
right like all of the all of the correct
arguments about this weird sex stuff
come on that's a slippery slope argument
come on we all know why it's wrong okay
then here's my challenge to you
tell me why it's wrong given the
premises on marriage on sex on
individual liberties or whatever that
we've all accepted in our modern
American way of life tell me why it is
wrong for gay or lesbian twins
siblings who they're not at risk of
procreation not at risk of creating a
child who's you know at higher risk for
certain abnormalities and therefore you
might make some some argument well the
child didn't consent or whatever kind of
lame moral arguments the modern Libs
make
tell me there's no risk of having a kid
why is that
why is incest between gay siblings wrong
if you if you can't explain it
then you I think you've got a very bad
case of liberal modernity
pink news wants to know why can't gay or
lesbian twins have sex with or marry
each other well
the reason is because to quote the Great
bioethicist
and philosopher and theologian Norm
Macdonald sex is a filthy shameful thing
that's obviously only meant for
procreation
which is not that answer from Norm is
actually about 85 percent right there's
a little more to it than that
but why well because sex is a very
powerful human thing and so we have this
um this institution which happens to be
the fundamental political institution
which is called marriage that actually
helps us to make sense of our sexual
desires and our sexual nature and
marriage is the union of one man and one
woman for the sake of the generation and
education of children and everyone
understood this until about five minutes
ago now that's all gone out the Wayside
and now we say What is marriage tell me
what marriage is
since 2015 since a distinct political
minority radically redefined marriage
against the will of the American people
kind of we're kind of like how a lot of
political movements take shape
regardless of their democratic
pretensions
when that happened then marriage became
the union of two people who love each
other regardless of their
sex
okay but my best friend and I we love
each other not that way but you know we
love each other so are we married no
we're not married because you have to I
guess you maybe have to have sex to be
mayor but no you don't have to have sex
to be married
there's no requirement that you will
have I mean that traditionally you had
to consummate a marriage for it to be
considered a marriage but that we've
redefined marriage that's not in there
so what is it is it well
if sexual difference isn't at the heart
of marriage okay if
then what is marriage
if it's just about two people who get a
certain romantic pleasure from one
another then why can't the twins do it
took consenting adults right well my
answer the conservative answer is
because consent is not all that matters
there are some behaviors that are wrong
many behaviors that are wrong actually
that are that are remain wrong and ought
to be suppressed including by the heavy
hand of the state
even if the adults sort of consent to it
the relationship between a drug dealer
and a drug addict
that is a seemingly consensual sort of
relationship
even though addiction compromises our
ability to consent just like all sin
compromises our ability to consent
because the man who sins is enslaved to
sin but let's say that you got the
relationship between a drug dealer the
heroine dealer and the heroin addict
today at least for now at least in most
of America we say that that consensual
relationship
is is illegal they cannot do the thing
that the drug dealers and the drug users
do together because there's there is a
higher moral consideration than consent
and we used to understand this about sex
that's certainly one of the arguments
against incest
but if we can't do that if we're not
allowing ourselves to articulate moral
considerations that are deeper
and higher actually than mere consent
then we're totally sunk then we're
totally lost
we're we're starting to work our way
back there a little bit you're seeing
this in the fight over the the Pediatric
gender clinics
even though still it's that moral
argument is still focused on consent
right the argument is the kids can't
consent and the parents are consenting
on behalf of the kids but the parents
are extremely deranged if they're
willing to take their kids in to get
their body parts chopped off so that a
little boys can seem more like little
girls and so we're saying that there's
no real consent going on here we got to
shut it down you know the rest of the
show
discontinuing now you do not want to
miss it we are going to be joined by my
friend
the great David Limbaugh if you are not
a member click a link in the description
and join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Music]